merci monsieur le président chers amis
conseillers nationaux
c'est un grand plaisir de m'exprimer
devant vous et de vous féliciter pour
votre élection vous qui représentez tous
les territoires de france dans nos
fédérations
vous êtes la force vive de notre famille
politique
alors tu l'as dit cheikh nicolas ne pas
renoncer à ses convictions je fais
partie de ceux qui ne renoncent jamais
je sais que nous sommes dans la
difficulté aujourd'hui la france sortira
du quinquennat de françois hollande
abîmé et meurtri et ce n'est pas un
remaniement politiciens à quinze mois de
l'échéance présidentielle qui changera
quelque chose
la france est économiquement affaibli
'l'annonce mensuelles des chiffres du
chômage est un rendez-vous d'angoise
pour nos compatriotes
alors que nos voisins renoue avec la
croissance et créer des emplois
nous continuons à nous enfoncer la
france ait déclassé
nous étions la cinquième puissance
mondiale nous sommes aujourd'hui sixième
notre notation financière a été une
nouvelle fois à dc en 2015
la france a perdu son leadership nous ne
sommes plus en initiatives sur la scène
internationale nous sommes à la remorque
de l'allemagne enfin la france est
attaquée en 2015 c'est la france qui
aura connu la plus violente vague
d'attentats sur le sol en europe sur son
sol en europe la france est attaqué sur
ses valeurs sur son socle fondateur
nous sommes aujourd'hui réunis pour
discuter de notre ligne politique et
c'est une bonne chose
c'est le fil rouge de nos idées et de
nos convictions qui s'appuiera sur un
diagnostic partagé
nous sommes tous d'accord d'ailleurs je
vous entends les uns après les autres
pour constater que notre compétitivité
lesté par nos charges trop lourdes par
nos impôts qui nous écrase par notre
budget national toujours déficitaire par
le poids de nos dépenses publiques par
aude notre organisation territoriale
encore plus complexifiés par la création
de vastes régions à l'identité dilué des
normes trop pesante nuit sur nos
entreprises
artisans et nos agriculteurs cher
nicolas je suis favorable à la
définition d'une base programmatique
commune à laquelle chacun puisse
contribuer mais nous sommes dans une
primaire et ce n'est pas aujourd'hui en
dix minutes le temps de dérouler indique
un programme présidentiel
chacun aura à présenter sa méthodologie
ses solutions pour la france
en usant de la liberté d'expression et
dans le respect de chacun
nous ne devons pas perdre de vue notre
objectif principal qui est de battre
françois hollande dont la politique si
néfaste est néfaste pour la france nous
serons tous d'accord sur le diagnostic
il suffit de regarder nos voisins
européens
nous travaillons en moyenne 200 heures
de moins qu'en allemagne qui a le budget
lui et elle en équilibre et commence à
se désendetter
sa balance commerciale affiche un record
en 2015 avec 248 milliards d'euros
d'excédent avec la même monnaie que nous
l'euro nous avons la même monnaie nous
payons le pétrole au même prix et
pourtant le chômage recule partout en
europe sauf chez nous c'est donc cette
politique mortifère pour notre économie
qui nous laisse aujourd'hui que nos
entreprises puissent décider de leur
durée légale du temps de travail dans
une fourchette comprise entre 35 et 40
heures
revenons de la liberté à nos entreprises
je suis favorable comme tu l'as dit au
référendum à l'intérieur deux aux
entreprises laissons les accords
d'entreprise qui peuvent déroger aux
accords de branche mais puisque nous
parlons de la france et que nous sommes
là pour parler de notre pays que nous
aimons tant
quelle france laisserons nous à nos
enfants alors je suis d'accord la france
est une idée la france est un idéal
c'est une espérance c'est une langue
c'est une histoire c'est une culture
mais c'est aussi 66 millions d'habitants
qui partagent une destinée commune
son histoire c'est aussi sa force son
rayonnement sa culture la france a des
racines chrétiennes
je suis né 58 ans après la loi sur la
laïcité adopté en 1905
j'ai grandi dans mon pays où les crèches
dans les lieux publics ne posaient pas
la moindre question elles appartiennent
à notre culture à nos traditions
c'était une joie à l'école de faire le
sapin de noël tout le monde y participe
et quelle que soit son origine
mes enfants sont nés dans les années 90
ils ont grandi dans cette époque où
notre vivre ensemble a commencé à être
attaqué par des provocations
communautariste avec le port du voile à
l'école
il nous a fallu répliqué par une loi le
communautarisme n'a cessé de se
développer et de croître du voile à
l'école nous sommes passés à la
provocation dans nos rues organisation
de prières de rue dans l'espace public
port du voile intégral
là aussi nous avons répliqué par une loi
qui n'est pas appliqué des ampoules sur
nos marchés dans nos rues des personnes
vêtues d'un niqab qui sautent autant de
publicité ambulante à l'islam radical
tu nous ne voulons pas chez nous et qui
le terreau du terrorisme intérieur
maintenant je suis grand mère et oui
l'année 2012 n'aura pas été que l'année
de l'échec ça aurait été aussi l'année
du bonheur est dans mon pays la france
ont fait un procès aux mairies qui
veulent mettre des crèches les vacances
de noël ne s'appelle plus vacances de
noël mes vacances d'hiver les vacances
de pâques ne s'appelle plus les vacances
de pâques mais les vacances de printemps
sur les chaînes publiques après la météo
on dit plus demain c'est la saint pierre
vous fêterez les pierres cette partie a
disparu
vous fêterez juste les pierres demain
devrons-nous baisser la tête
renier la france éternelle je vous le
demande je souhaite inscrire nos racines
chrétiennes dans notre constitution la
république est laïque
la france a des racines chrétiennes et
chacun doit y pratiquer son culte en
toute liberté
mais la france a des racines chrétiennes
et nous devons les faire respecter
j'espère que je ne vous ai pas choqué
non parce que j'entends certains de nos
amis nous faire un procès en
droitisation j'ai toujours trouvé cela
étonnant je suis de droite
je devrais m'en excuser ne tombons pas
dans le piège tendu par nos adversaires
cela nous a mené droit à la défaite
faut-il que je me gauchise pour être
dans le vent
je n'ai pas grand chose en commun avec
ceux qui mettent aujourd'hui la france
par terre je ne cours pas après le front
national
je cours après ces français désespéré
qui cherchent une parole de vérité qui
veulent être protégés qui ont besoin
d'être compris qu'ils existent des
résultats nous devons pas transiger avec
nos valeurs et notre culture
celui qui est accueillie chez nous doit
s'adapter à nos modes de vie et non l
inverse
j'ai été choqué de voir qu'à rome au
passage du président de la république
d'iran il a fallu cacher certaines
statues parce que c'étaient des nues
rappelez-vous l'iran dans les années 70
les femmes porter des minijupes
rappelez-vous la turquie la tunisie de
bourguiba aujourd'hui c'est le droit des
femmes qui est menacée quand on soumet
les femmes en france
c'est à la france et à notre république
qu'on s'attaque
nous devons être intransigeant sur la
défense de nos valeurs
sinon c'est une injure faite à toutes
celles qui se battent pour leur liberté
dans ces pays où on lapide mes chers
amis c'est un sujet grave autant plus
grave que nous traversons une vague
migratoire de masse sans précédent
disons le c'est une invasion à laquelle
l'europe n'oppose que son impuissance
la commission européenne a proposé une
politique irresponsable de répartition
de quotas de migrants avec l'assentiment
du gouvernement socialistes français au
parlement européen
j'ai voté contre les quotas de migrants
c'est une politique d'incitation à
l'immigration illégale
je me suis rendu dans les camps de
réfugiés au liban et en jordanie
je me suis entretenu avec les réfugiés
j'ai mesuré leur dénuement leur détresse
face à une communauté internationale
incapable de régler la crise en syrie
depuis le printemps arabe c'est le chaos
dans ce secteur du monde
les réfugiés ne veulent pas venir en
europe ils préféraient rester chez eux
mais ils attendent de nous que nous
intervenions l'a pas politiquement
diplomatiquement militairement
parce qu'il faut régler le problème en
syrie parce qu'il faut et il faut faire
avec bachar el assad parce qu'il faut
une coalition internationale avec la
russie parce qu'il faut régler le
problème de la libye que monsieur
hollande a voulu cacher dissimulé et
puis il n'est pas intervenu tout
simplement parce que nicolas sarkozy
était allé intervenir en libye et ils
avaient eu raison j'en terminerai par
vous dire comme aujourd'hui la jungle de
calais est devenu une honte pour la
france pays des droits de l'homme
quand on voit comment vivre ses citoyens
si genre en situation illégale
ces habitants de calais qui ne supporte
plus ce qui se passe quand on voit que
le gouvernement socialiste a choisi non
pas de régler le problème et le de le
disperser en répartissant les migrants
dans nos villages dans nos villages vous
savez que chez moi est arrivé dans un
village de 600 habitants
onze immigrés en situation illégale
la préfecture a décidé de les mettre
dans un château dans une colonie de
vacances
on n'aurait pas fait ça pour nos sans
domicile fixe eh bien on a réparti des
migrants dans un château où ils ne
savent pas quoi faire de l'agît rien
faire de la journée
alors on a payé une association pour les
occuper on a renforcé la sécurité avec
une compagnie de gendarmerie
mais on a dispersé les problèmes et
alors sur les onze migrants qui sont
arrivés ça fait pas longtemps il ya
quelques jours il y en a déjà cinq qui
sont partis et quand j'ai demandé au
maire mais ils sont partis mais ils sont
partis ou abandonner ses pas et voilà la
réalité la réalité c'est que aujourd'hui
nous n'aurait nous narrera compagnon pas
chez eux ceux qui sont en situation
illégale et qu'il n'aurait jamais fallu
ça je le dis à nicolas saint paul des
accords sans doute avec nous avec lui il
a eu raison de créer le ministère de
l'immigration il a eu raison
mais je pense qu'il a eu tort de le
supprimer parce qu'aujourd'hui on
enverrait toute son utilité de ce
ministère de l'immigration parce que
l'union européenne ne remplit pas sa
tâche mais la france pourrait remplir au
moins la 6ème et ce ministère de nuit
oui c'est une réalité de pardon un petit
dialogue entre nous mais c'est vrai mais
il avait pris une bonne initiative et je
crois qu'il faut absolument continuer à
le faire parce que nous avons besoin
d'un vrai service public de reconduite
nous avons besoin de signer aussi des
conventions de réadmission avec beaucoup
de pays
aujourd'hui tout cela n'est pas fait
alors pour l'amour de la france faisant
en sorte en 2017 de la remettre debout
et faisant au sort aussi de préserver
son équilibre culturel vive la france et
8 mai le public